[Music]
[Music]
sometimes I like to pretend that I'm
King James blessed by the gods to choose
my army my Lord Commander and my home
but alas I am NOT I am sir marShon
Brooks the journeyman cell sword who not
long ago was fighting in the distant
lands of China's spending years
reassembling what remained of my
shattered spirit only to land a seat on
the dreary benches of Memphis but fate
is a curious thing for yesterday
how sons requested my services and
offered real assets in return
so trevor ariza and picks seems i shall
finally proved to everyone that i am a
knight worthy of minutes and what i once
feared was my twilight was in fact my
dorm welcome to house suns
thank you sir marShon Brooks at your
service
wait marShon Brooks yes actually we
traded for Darren Brooks you were they
sent the wrong Brook house Wesley sent
the wrong Brooks are you bloody serious
oh how the fickle tides of fate proceed
as quickly as they crash upon my shorts
and though my sandcastles may were there
and wash the deft hands of hope must
always be there
[Music]
dears Jennifer I've received your Raven
and I beseech you understand
I am trying I try every day to bring you
the ring you so desire the Boogie Knight
himself they say our bigs can't defend
please I've got a torn Achilles last I
saw this lot
you all were getting swept away faster
than a Horace Mann KSAT house Mavericks
oh please boogie regale us with the
tales of your extensive tournament
experience better none than yours don't
let him get in your head oh good on you
all for giving Jimmer another shot what
no I'm wait I'm not going to fall for
your hurtful tricks anymore you see it
seems the tables have turned
unlike you I have to put Achilles and
friends have you like my socks now [ __ ]
what a fellowship you all have almost
makes up for the lack of rings the Lord
of Light parted locker room chemistry
smiles upon our brotherhood who smiles
upon you boogie he's gone her rings hand
no friends to which of those can you
offer me friends I prefer rings within
join us together we shouldn't make it
past the second round whoa whoa I don't
want this guy here he's like mess with
our flow and I mean we have like good
vibes and also like we have same agent
and he says it might affect my minutes
doesn't matter
it's water under the bay bridge I'm
signing with house warriors what No he's
full of it everybody knows House
Warriors over the gold cap they can't
afford you know it's probably mid-level
exception it's it's an exception I of
course know what that isn't fully
understanding my mind is buzzing for
iron a heart
tagging casino geek cousins turned into
a snake hey boys to the Oakland's
winners rings all who round give his
head bando rebrand as a ring chasers
crowd
love for bar Fridays boogie damn the
only thing more hopeless than this
Brotherhood is your bard career you know
I expect it to be a bastard but a coward
- I'd rather die the chin a quart with
curry no no sorry I mean the good
I mean Steph and the rest of those we've
got no chance we had no chance but we do
now the lord of light hearted chemistry
is very powerful to the humble
he giveth but to the greedy he take it
away
the Warriors defeat can only come from
within no house can bear the likes of
dream on KD and causes their golden cup
runneth over with [ __ ] let him go
hope you enjoy the regular season you
[ __ ] losers I hope y'all get a good
AC so I can see your faces when we sweep
you again I'll crush you like I crushed
my Lord Commander to see know the way
out of here
now get himself a jacket eventually my
mind gives up buzzing fired a heart
attack seems big bulky cousins turned
into a snake he rides to do plans when
it rings all around give his head man
brand as a retraces crown huh Oh raving
has brought us some news that is good
house blazes acquired the night Rodney
on by let's see Reverend rejoice at your
chair example Nik Stauskas y'all now
apparently my boy hey good luck in
Cleveland Nick if you enjoy game of
zones please consider subscribing it
lets us know you support the show and we
can notify you when new episodes come
out have you subscribed marquel no I
tried to subscribe but I missed